-Your blood pressure
is 59 over 2.
And our X-rays...
found a canoe
in your Achilles' heel.
[ Laughter ]
It also appears that you have
a rare condition
known as
Fluffy Platypus Disease.
♪♪
Kenan, I wanted to try
something fun with you.
I thought we could act out
a dramatic scene together.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Yeah.
-Let me get my chops on.
-But first we have to fill in
the blanks, 'cause it's time for
"Mad Lib Theater." Here we go.
-♪ "Mad Lib Theater,"
ah, ah, yeah ♪
-Now here to help us out
is a great actor
who stars in the new movie
"Bottom of the 9th."
Everyone please welcome
Joe Manganiello!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah That's what
I'm talking about! Buddy!
Look at that.
Joe Manganiello! Come on.
Joe, welcome.
Thank you for helping us out.
-Want me to sit?
-Yeah, sit.
-All right.
Here's the way this --
I'm gonna ask you both
for some silly words.
Nouns, verbs, adjectives,
et cetera.
And as we do that, they'll
be written onto cue cards,
and then we're gonna act out
a dramatic Mad Libs scene.
Ready for this?
-Yeah. Really dramatic.
-All right, yeah.
Very dramatic.
All right, Kenan,
give me a silly word.
-Silly word. "Butt."
[ Laughter ]
-Joe, food at a barbecue?
-Heinz Ketchup.
-Thanks. Adjective?
-Funky.
-Cartoon character?
-Hong Kong Phooey.
-Wow! Nice!
-Deep cut.
-Wow!
Hong Kong Phooey, man.
[ Laughter ]
Kenan, give me a state.
-Georgia.
-Uh, a plural occupation.
-Plural occupation?
-Yes.
-Farmhands.
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-First thing
that came to mind.
-Oh, my gosh. Country.
-United States of America.
-There you go, buddy. USA.
A plural item of clothing.
-Plural item of clothing.
Um, oh, I just came from Europe,
and this is on
your laundry list,
for men and women -- panties.
-Interesting.
-Panties.
If you send underwear,
like, your boxer shorts,
to get washed at a hotel,
you have to check
the "panties" box.
-Are you serious?
-Swear, yeah.
-Just be open
to new experiences.
-Listen.
Jimmy, just go with it.
-I'm going with it.
Kenan, give me a number.
-1,100,060.
[ Laughter ]
-Not making this easy on him.
-Yeah. Wow.
All right. Give me a month.
-A month. December.
-Is that your birthday?
-It is.
-A type of salad.
-Greek.
-Joe, a greeting
that you give your puppy
after being gone the entire day.
-"Oooh, you little..."
-Oooh, you...
-O-O-O...
-Oooh, you little...
"Oooh, you little..."
Kenan, a verb ending in I-N-G.
-Fastening.
Doing a lot of fastening
of the shoes lately.
-I'm tying --
-Fastening.
-I'm teaching my daughter
how to tie her shoes.
Lot of fastening.
-Your daughter's 36, right?
-Yeah.
She's doing really well.
We're proud of her.
-Joe, celebrity name.
-Kim Kardashian.
-There you go.
-I don't know why --
-That's great.
-Celebrity.
-Kim Kardashian.
Kenan, what you shout
when you find out
you've been accepted
to the college of your dreams.
-"How much?!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's it. A plural noun.
-Plural noun.
-Yep.
-Um, um -- Bananas.
Ba-non-as. Ba-non-as.
-Ba-non-as.
Past-tense verb.
-What? Past-tense verb?
Sorry.
Ran?
-Yep.
-Was that a past-tense verb?
-Yeah.
Another plural
article of clothing.
-Gosh. Clip-on ties.
[ Laughter ]
-Gotta have 'em.
-Clip-on ties.
-Body part.
-Foot.
-A noun.
Um, uh, Chicago.
-Yeah. Place.
-Person, place, or thing.
-Yeah.
-That's a thing. Yeah.
-First noun -- Chicago.
That's right.
Kenan, food you'd order
at a sushi restaurant.
-Shrimp tempura roll.
-Yeah, okay.
Shrimp tempura roll.
-And delicious.
-A childhood punishment.
-Childhood punishment.
The bar of soap in the mouth.
-All right.
Now we're gonna do --
This is the speed round here.
Real quick right here.
Kenan, exclamation.
-Hooray!
-Another verb ending in I-N-G.
-Um, uh, uh, beating.
-Beating.
-Wow.
-I don't --
Oh, my God, I can't even --
It started with farmhands.
That's when
it went off the rails.
Farmhands.
-Farmhands.
-That's all right. I'm good.
Mall restaurant.
-Uh, whew.
We'll go with Taco Bell.
-Taco Bell. There you go.
Mall clothing store.
-Mall clothing store.
Um, um, Spencer's?
Spencer's Gifts.
They have T-shirts.
-I guess they have --
They have clothing there?
-Yeah, T-shirts --
-And, like, young
adolescent pornography.
-Yes, they do.
Spencer's Gifts. There you go.
We've filled out
the words for our scene.
Let's go perform the scene.
Let's do this right now.
Are you guys ready?
-Let's do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Organ playing cheerful music ]
♪♪
-All right.
Welcome back, baseball fans.
I'm Steve Butt.
Alongside me is my co-announcer,
Kyle Heinz Ketchup.
-Thank you very much.
No relation. No relation.
We're live on this
beautiful, funky night
from the historic
Hong Kong Phooey Stadium.
We're gonna change that.
-We're in the ninth inning
of a very close matchup
between the Georgia Farmhands
versus the United States
of America Panties.
-That's --
-The score is tied
1,100,060 to 1,100,060.
-Wow. This is very exciting.
Joining us now
is our special guest.
Retired all-star pitcher.
None other than the one and only
December Greek.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oooh, you little...!
Great to be here tonight.
I've never seen a stadium
with so many fans
fastening so loudly.
-It's been quite a game.
Lots of great moments so far.
Including when Kim Kardashian
streaked across the field.
-How much?!
I can't believe that!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right.
-Wow. Wow.
-Now, December Greek,
you hold the record
for most bananas ran --
-I think you mean ba-non-as.
-Ba-non-as.
-That's right.
-Did you have
any pregame superstitions?
-Actually, yes, I did.
Before every game, I would
go into the locker room,
put on fresh clip-on ties,
and rub my foot
with my lucky Chicago.
-Wow! Wow!
-That's a very popular noun --
Chicago.
A very popular noun.
-Back to the game --
-That's what I think of first.
The word Chicago,
that's a great noun.
-Back to the game.
Stepping up to the plate
is Mike Shrimp Tempura Roll.
-Uh-huh.
-Oh, here we go.
Bases loaded, full count.
If Mike Shrimp Tempura Roll
doesn't get a hit,
his manager is gonna get
a bar of soap in the mouth.
-All right.
-There it is.
-Here's the pitch.
He swings! There it goes!
Hooray! It is gone!
-Yeah.
He's beating around the bases.
I've never seen this before.
-What a game!
All right, guys, it's time
to sing our favorite song.
-♪ Take me out
to the Taco Bell ♪
♪ Take me out
to the Spencer's ♪
♪ For it's one, two,
three strikes, you're out ♪
♪ At the old Taco Bell ♪
-And scene!
My thanks to Kenan Thompson,
Joe Manganiello!
Now, Kristen, I wanted
to try something fun with you.
I thought that we could act out
a dramatic scene together.
-Yes. Okay.
-Okay? But first we have to
fill in the blanks.
It is time for "Mad Lib
Theater." Here we go.
-♪ "Mad Lib Theater,"
ah, ah, yeah ♪
-[ Laughing ] Yes!
-What?
-That was amazing.
-♪ "Mad Lib Theater" ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-[ Laughs ]
-That was fantastic.
-I loved it.
-All right.
Here's how this works.
This is "Mad Lib Theater."
So here, I'm going to ask you
for some silly words.
-Okay.
-Nouns, verbs, adjectives.
And they're going to be written
on cue cards as you say them,
and then we'll act out
a dramatic Mad Libs scene.
Are you ready? Here we go.
-Okay. Yes.
-Silly word.
-Gooby...
[ Laughter ]
Gooby gock?
-Gooby gock.
Type of fish.
-Mackerel.
-He's on the show tonight, too.
[ Laughter ]
Adjective.
-Swirling.
[ Light laughter ]
-What you would shout
if you saw a ghost.
-Get out, you!
[ Laughter ]
-A number.
-59.
-Another number.
-2.
-A noun.
-Canoe?
-A body part.
-Achilles' heel.
[ Laughter ]
-Another adjective.
-Uh, drinking.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, oh, adjective. Sorry.
Sorry.
-Yeah. It's a describer.
-Sorry, sorry.
-No, I'm sorry. It's tough.
-Fluffy.
-Yeah.
That's good.
A type of animal?
-Uh...platypus.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, man.
A curse word that you'd say
in front of a child.
-Um...toot.
[ Laughter ]
-Amount of time,
like two minutes or five hours.
-Oh, um, uh...two...hours.
-Verb ending in "ing."
-Drinking.
-There you go.
Hey, Kristen is playing
the game, okay?
Come on.
-They can help.
-Yeah. They can help, yeah.
Drinking.
Another body part.
-Armpit.
-A verb.
-Hammering.
-Yeah, okay, yeah.
Hammering.
A verb ending in "ing."
Sorry.
-Oh, oh.
Oh, a different one?
-A different one, now.
-Biting.
[ Laughter ]
-Adjective.
-Striped.
-A type of profession.
-A cruise director.
[ Laughter ]
-Cruise director.
Oh, these are great.
Type of relative.
-Second cousin.
Male name.
-Gary.
-Made-up song title.
-"Feel My Face."
[ Laughter ]
-"Feel My Face." All right.
We filled out the words
for our scene.
You ready to perform?
-Yes.
-Here we go.
Let's go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, if it isn't
my favorite patient,
Mr. Gooby Gock.
-Thanks for seeing me on such
short notice, Dr. Mackerel.
So, what's the news?
-Well, we just finished
processing your test,
and unfortunately,
the results are swirling.
-Get out, you!
[ Laughter ]
-I completely understand
that reaction.
Your blood pressure
is 59 over 2.
And our X-rays found a canoe
in your Achilles' heel.
[ Laughter ]
It also appears that you have
a rare condition
known as
Fluffy Platypus Disease.
[ Laughter ]
-Toot!
Is there any way to cure it?
-I'm going to write you
a prescription for these pills
right here
that I have in my pocket.
I want you to take one
every two hours.
-But I heard those pills cause
involuntary drinking.
-I'm afraid they do.
Side effects also include
an itchy armpit
and a decrease
in the desire to hammer.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That a medical term?
Uh, wh--
[ Laughter ]
What can I do to stay healthy?
-I would suggest
waking up early...
-[ Laughs ]
-...every morning
and doing stretches
and then biting in the park.
[ Laughter ]
-That's great advice,
especially for a striped
cruise director such as myself.
-You know, the best part
about being a doctor
is that I get to treat
patients like you
and then go home
to my second cousin, Gary...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...and then sing them
my favorite song.
-Which is?
-"Feel My Face."
[ Groans ]
-How does it go?
Can you sing it for me?
[ Laughter ]
"Feel My Face."
-Yes.
♪ You and me gotta get
out of this place ♪
♪ And come back to apartment
so you can feel my face ♪
♪ Touch my body, touch my body ♪
-Thank you very much, Doctor.
I appreciate it.
-I'm so sorry.
-Uh, no, please.
And scene!
That is how you do it
right there.
Kristen Wiig!
That's how you do it!